this week
is agriculture in need of another
revolution the big thing in agriculture
is everyone's saying well what can we do
to to get
farmers to voluntarily contribute to
carbon sequestration
bid ag gets a bad rep when it comes to
sustainability
but with the help of new technologies
can it clean up its act
today we estimate that approximately one
in nine people
in the world experience what we would
call food insecurity
higher prices and lower accessibility
have forced millions into food poverty
why greater supply doesn't always mean
fewer empty bellies
everyone says how do we fight climate
change well we plant trees
and so we're basically planting a
rainforest under the sea how one of the
world's fastest growing plants could
provide an alternative to traditional
agriculture
as well as a climate solution i'm kaley
lines
and this is bloomberg green
[Music]
first up let's get your roundup of
climate news with jennifer zabazadja
this is bloomberg green i'm jennifer
zabasanja in new york with your green
brief that ruthless heat wave across the
u.s northwest has triggered
rolling blackouts this week according to
power outage u.s
it affected more than 30 thousand
customers across washington
and oregon the temperatures are
threatening to blow transformers and
strain
power lines airline industry group iata
says it will ask carriers to go
net zero by 2050. it comes as pressure
builds on the sector
over its continued use of fossil fuels
some big airlines have already made
commitments but the group
hasn't updated its own goal in over a
decade
the world's biggest carbon market is set
to get stronger with the eu planning
tougher limits on emitters the changes
are part of a package to transform
every sector of the economy a draft plan
shows the price of polluting in the
block could rise more than
50 percent by the end of the decade and
lego thinks it may have found the
building blocks to become
more sustainable it's unveiled a new
prototype brick made from recycled
plastic the toy company has set aside
about
400 million dollars to go green and
that's your green
brief kaley thanks jen
farming and food production is one of
the most polluting industries on the
planet
with some estimates finding it
responsible for as much as 40
percent of annual global emissions the
gases are released from livestock soils
and the exhaust pipes of farm vehicles
all of which are key battlegrounds in
the race to make farming
green with the need to feed more and
more people
comes the necessary economies of scale
the average farm in the usa has grown in
size from just over 200 acres in 1950
to around 450 acres in 2019.
if the birth of big ag was a necessity
is it inevitable that it is superseded
by something else
joining us now to discuss is agnieszka
d'souza our food and agriculture
reporter in
london aggie what changes does
agriculture have to make to get better
for the climate
many many changes in a way agriculture
is both the victim and perpetrator of
climate change so not only does it have
to
adapt to the changing weather
it also has to make radical changes in
the way
it produces it delivers food you know
it's a
major source of carbon emissions but
it's also polluting to soil
water because of the use of conventional
inputs such as fertilizers pesticides
and so on
so in a way all of that has to be
overhauled or tweaked and addressed
and you know we already have new
technologies emerging new farming
techniques you know we were hearing more
and more about uh
regenerative agriculture that is um
really focusing on the health of the
soil and addressing that aspect
uh so there are many ways to to get this
done we just have to kind of move
forward with it
it's one thing to make agriculture more
sustainable it's another thing to then
scale it how big of a problem is that
yes indeed um scalability like with
many other climate solution is the key
you know can we scale it
and what is crucial for farming really
as well is how do you incentivize
farmers to actually switch
to other techniques to implement those
technologies and new methods
how do you create markets incentives
investment
in order to do it so i think overall all
those
questions lead to how we achieve
scalability and that is why
in a way if you can recruit
um big companies and a big act to
actually do it and to help
with it because of their vast
distribution network because of their
vast
influence that could certainly help
the un food systems summit is coming up
later this year these are obviously
questions that are going to come up
there
is big ag going to be responsive to some
of these new ideas
and are they already taking steps in
that direction
um indeed the unit the u1 is holding a
major
food systems conference later this year
and it's trying to bring
all types of stakeholders to the table
uh you know main questions being asked
uh
will be how do we produce food that is
good
both for the health of people and health
of the planet
and it is trying to include
different types of stakeholders so
business is
included at the end of the day the
question is
um you know will the summit result
in any visible pledges and commitments i
think the
what big ag and big business and
government
and so on will do will depend whether
there actually
are gonna be a strong commitment and i
think in a sense we need that
similar to uh what has been achieved
during climate summits all right thanks
so much to our food and agriculture
reporter agnieszka de souza in london
coming up in the u.s despite having more
wealth than average
farmers are given billions in government
funding every year
but that money has few strings attached
missing the chance to incentivize more
sustainable farming
we speak to a former chief economist of
the usda
this is bloomberg green
[Music]
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kaley lines and this
is bloomberg green data shows u.s
farming households have more wealth than
average
thanks to the significant capital value
of their assets
despite this farmers received 28 billion
dollars in two years from the trump
administration
in the form of disaster relief and trade
war bailouts
economists now say this was a missed
opportunity to push american farming to
go green
we spoke with joe glauber senior
research fellow at the international
food policy institute in washington
about big agriculture in the u.s he was
previously the chief economist for the
usda
for six years starting in 2008.
the u.s is a major food exporter they're
a major
food supplier to the world according to
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change
agriculture together with forestry
accounts for about 25
of global greenhouse gases for the u.s i
believe it's more closer to 10
for agriculture but that's not to say
that agriculture isn't a big
emitter certainly the big sources are
methane
and methane essentially means animal
production although rice paddies
generate methane but animal agriculture
is really the big one
agriculture has essentially been outside
of the
direct conversation on regulation even
if you were to go back to
2009 2010 when congress was considering
regulating greenhouse gas there were no
proposals to directly regulate them like
you would say
through a carbon tax or something like
that the big thing in agriculture is
everyone's saying well what can we do to
to get farmers to voluntarily contribute
to carbon
sequestration and of course that's
essentially subsidies
agriculture is one of the most
subsidized industries in the united
states
they were paid about 28 billion for
the trade war with china they received
another 23
24 billion for covid by
september for the most part prices were
above what they had been fired at the
coronavirus yet there was they were
still putting in the second tranche of
coronavare's payments the third trash
and now
secretary vilsack announced you know
another trash of payments for form this
was on
top of standing safety net programs that
provide them support when prices fall
you can make a much better case for
those programs
if you could tie environmental benefits
to them agricultural payments are mainly
tied to production
or historical production so it benefits
large landowners
who are we talking about when we talk
about a farm if you talk about the the
people who produce
the stuff that is humans consume or
animals consume it's grown on farms
it's like 15 of the farms so roughly 250
to 300 000 produce 85 to 90 percent of
what's produced in this country
generally if you look at the median
household income
it's far above the median household
income of the rest
of the population but while the
agricultural industry was getting aid
from the usda
another program it administers was being
cut
snap you have this disparity we've seen
the last two or three years
the rates of malnourishment under
nourishment have have increased
at the same time where we have rates of
obesity increasing in spending this web
of subsidies and incentives
the true whack-a-mole nature of
regulation is confronted
unless you really get a big shift in
diets people are still going to want to
have beef
the us is a huge livestock producer
obviously but we're also
pretty efficient for every pound of meat
that's produced
we have a relatively low level of
greenhouse gases compared to
other livestock producing systems some
will point out that
if you were to do things like try to
curtail that production in the u.s you
actually could
shift production to other areas where
you actually may get more greenhouse
gases
[Music]
livestock farming makes up almost 15
percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions
and a significant part of that is burped
straight out of the mouths of cows
bottling these burps could be a big win
in the fight to cut emissions from a
notoriously tricky industry
luckily one startup is tackling the
problem with a novel innovation in
bovine fashion
cow masks
[Music]
agricultural food giant cargill plans to
start
selling wearable devices designed
to curb methane emissions from cattle
the wearables that look kind of like
masks
have been designed and developed by a uk
startup called zell
livestock farming accounts for a
substantial
share of agricultural emissions in fact
it actually
makes up 14.5 of greenhouse gas
emissions globally and that's mainly
because
cattle ship or other remnants
release methane basically a result of
their
peculiar unique digestive
systems most of that methane
goes out through cow's mouth as they
burp
[Music]
zelps wearables get placed just above
cows mouths
essentially a set of funds powered by
batteries
will suck up the burps and trap them
in the chamber with a methane absorbing
filter
and once that filter is saturated a
chemical reaction
turns the methane into carbon dioxide
which is then released in the air it's
still a greenhouse gas
but methane is much worse so converting
it into
co2 is still a win
the devices are not the only solution
out there in fact there is a quest
to find the most effective way
to curb methane emissions feed
supplements
or additives are being tested
and developed right now more work needs
to be done
in order to gauge how effective these
solutions are
and scientists are looking into it
we know that most of these solutions
cannot fully eliminate methane emissions
from cattle
farmers do need financial incentives in
order to use them
perhaps one of the ways to help farmers
would be to give an opportunity to offer
this
climate smart milk or meat at a premium
to standard product
meat production and dairy production are
still
expected to grow in the next years
and that's largely because consumption
is growing
in in many markets especially in
emerging markets so
we we won't eliminate cattle
overnight the production will be ongoing
so it's so important to actually find
solutions
that will address livestock's footprint
dairy and meat companies many food
producers are under pressure from their
investors and also consumers to reduce
their carbon footprint
[Music]
coming up farming the sea how one
company is growing kelp as a sustainable
alternative
foodstock this is bloomberg green
[Music]
from bloomberg's headquarters in new
york i'm kalie lymes and this
is bloomberg green the basics of farming
haven't changed much
since humans started tilling fields you
need seeds
water and most of all land but since
most of our planet is water
farming the sea could provide a much
needed boost to global food stocks
akua is a company attempting to do just
that producing kelp-based food that
requires no inputs of land
fresh water or fertilizer and that sucks
in carbon
as it grows our janet wu went to
investigate the
based company fighting climate change
through ocean farming
[Music]
what is this what are we looking at here
yeah so this is actually
this is a kelp farm we're 10 acres which
is
it's a lot of a lot of area for the bay
and there's a lot going on
under the surface that you can't see
she's farming one of the fastest growing
plants on earth
what began as microscopic seeds in
november
just seven months later these kelp lines
are
you know average i say three feet long
and still growing it's getting bigger
every day
colleen was still lobstering when she
met tulip olsen
the man who built the first kelp farm in
america i kind of looked at him then
this is like i said like 15 years ago
it's like tall if i don't know man
i don't know if this is going to go and
once i once we got into the process and
built those first farms and i saw
you know what what his vision was i was
like you know there is something here
the very first kelp farm in the united
states
was right there here in casco bay maine
now there are more than a hundred farms
in maine alone
the industry is growing as fast as the
kelp
the global commercial seaweed market is
projected to surpass
85 billion dollars by 2026.
right now 98 of the seaweed you buy in
stores
comes from asia or seaweed aquaculture
dates back
1700 years kelp farming
is amazing it requires no fresh water
no fertilizers no feed and at the same
time that it's growing it's just sucking
up
nutrients from the water it's also
cleaning the water
it's sucking up carbon it
photosynthesizes like a land plant but
apparently it's like 20 times more
efficient this stuff is amazing
and then you end up with this this
superfood
so this is it oh my gosh it's heavy it
is heavy yeah
a superfood but not something many
people want to eat
like this this is really delicious
that's where akua comes in the key
vitamins and minerals you're going to
find in calp are a and k
from a mineral standpoint calcium
potassium magnesium
zinc some omega-3s courtney boyd meyers
and her partner launched akua four years
ago
with the multiple goals of building a
sustainable business
fighting climate change and creating new
foods
so much of our soil today is depleted of
vitamins and minerals because of the way
that we're you know mono cropping and
the oceans are still
rich in it so you know we're sucking
that in with the kelp
and putting it into a burger and and
you're eating it
the patty is made with mushrooms pea
protein black beans
chickpea flour and extra virgin olive
oil
but the main ingredient is kelp
it's not meant to mimic meat but offer a
satisfying alternative
with a rich umami flavor to date we've
secretly sold over 20
000 kelp burgers and it's our goal to
have a hundred thousand dollar month
this july
during the pandemic akua raised a
million dollars through crowd funding
good girl this season it will buy out
colleen's entire 30 thousand pound crop
i've always wanted to come back to
aquaculture because of its
sustainability
and after seeing years ago what you know
what the potential was for kelp
and the ways it really positively
impacts the environment
that makes me feel like it's a good
business to start
some of it's absolutely beautiful look
at that our company's goal is for every
five million dollars in revenue that
we're earning
we're pulling one million pounds of
harmful carbon out of the sea
via the kelp that we're using you know
everyone says how do we fight climate
change well we plant trees
and so we're basically planting a rain
forest under the sea
a hidden rain forest quietly cleaning
the ocean
while growing into the base of healthy
new foods
agriculture's carbon footprint is far
from its only issue
despite producing enough food to feed 10
billion people
much of the world's population continues
to go hungry
this has only been worsened by the
pandemic during which prices have
skyrocketed and access
has decreased leaving millions
struggling to get food
add to that rampant food waste where
roughly one third of the total
production is lost every year
and big agriculture is crying out for a
green revolution
let's bring in jessica eyes visiting
professor of social and environmental
challenges at the university of texas
san
antonio professor let's just frame this
problem first
in many rich countries we don't have to
worry about food supply
or shortages that is definitely not the
case everywhere
how many people in the world are hungry
today
we estimate that approximately one in
nine people
in the world experience what we would
call food insecurity
so there's a difference between acute
malnutrition and food insecurity
so food insecurity would be where you
just don't have the confidence that you
can get the food that you need every day
to have the health that you need and
acute malnutrition would be what we
consider to be people starving
actively how does climate change factor
into this
can you give me some specific examples
about how
changing climate affects food supply so
agriculture is actually one of the
industries that is most
impacted by climate change because when
you think about it our crops are heavily
dependent upon the climate
so they require particular conditions
for the food to grow
for instance they need particular
temperatures they need particular
precipitation levels
and what we know about climate change is
it impacts the average temperatures in
particular regions
but it also impacts what we would call
incidence of extreme weather
so certain regions of the world might be
experiencing drought
whereas others might be experiencing
increased temperatures and increased
rainfall
and that means that each farmer in that
region with their particular crop
needs to come up with unique adaptation
strategies and
for some farmers that even means that
you don't grow the crop that you used to
historically grow in that area
but aside from switching the crop that
you are farming are there different
methods to farming that can create some
kind of adaptation
so there are different methods and
people are experimenting with a lot of
these right now and this is an area
where we need to focus a lot of
innovation and attention
in the future so we can ensure that we
don't have massive food shortages
so some of these examples that we could
look at are
genetically modified organisms so people
are modifying
certain crops to be more resilient
against drought
so for instance if there's areas in the
world that are experienced that is
experiencing drought on a regular basis
now they might modify
the seed to be slightly more resilient
against that shortage
so that we can grow better we're also
looking at precision farming
so using technology to understand what
part of the field
might need more fertilizer or less
fertilizer or what might need more water
or less water
and in this way we can actually be more
sustainable too
in using precision agriculture
techniques because we would only apply
fertilizer or we would only water in
areas in the field that
really need it and we could spare the
areas that don't need it
how difficult is it to scale some of
those innovations and new techniques
right i think you hit the nail on the
head because one of the greatest
challenges
with technology at the beginning is
making it scalable
because it's quite can be quite
expensive so
when you talk about big agriculture i
think you're talking about the larger
farms
in more industrialized or wealthier
countries
so in those cases these might be early
adopters of these technologies but in a
lot of places in the world
a lot of farmers are still smallholder
farmers and a lot of those
smallholder farmers we rely on for a lot
of our food
and in those cases these technologies
are too expensive they're inaccessible
to them
so expense is a big challenge at the
beginning when it comes to making
technology scalable
but a second one is making these
technologies actually appropriate to the
realities of the farmers themselves
thanks to jessica i's visiting professor
of social and environmental challenges
at the university of texas san antonio
that's it for this week's edition but
keep the conversation going
follow us on twitter at climate i'm
kaylie lynes in new york
and this is bloomberg green
you